across nevada are getting help trying to  rebuild and stay afloat  after the pandemic forced closures and  widespread layoffs  the employee nevada business hub as you  see there just reopened over or just  opened rather at the sahara west library  the goal is to have workforce  development professionals help local  businesses with recruiting hiring and  training  you have multiple agencies multiple  funding streams coming together to make  it easier for the employers  they don't have to go to multiple places  here you find all those resources under  one roof  this is the second location for these  job hubs here in las vegas the other one  is over at the vegas chamber  employee nevada business hub is open to  all businesses  at no cost if you at home are looking  for work right now we do have a section  of our website with a list of companies  that are hiring  just go to eightnewsnow.com if you click  on job board at the top of the homepage  you'll get everything you need to know